I mean, gay people don't contribute anything to society at all.
Consent doesn't exist in marriage. >> We don't take women
to vote. >> And this is why I say all the time that I'm
an anti-feminist because modern feminism is poison. >> Without
this like latent homophobia, I'd have no idea Kidology was black.
Okay. This is one of the gayest pictures I've ever seen taken
in my entire life. This is like explicitly like the gayest picture
I've ever seen. >> And to them, and I don't think it comes
from true happiness. And I think it really does come out of insecurity
from being in frankly a lavender marriage as everyone online
can see. >> I disagree. I think so. >> Are you that
easily manipulated by Tik Tok rumors?
>> Oh, that kidology video. I wouldn't mind doing that
for a little bit. There's I think Riyle requested this video.
Riyle loves Kiddology so much. I don't know if you guys know
that. Riyle like absolutely loves Kiddology. Sends me Kodology
videos to review all the time. Like crazy. Riyle's just a big
fan of black women. That's what I'm saying. >> Seems to
be the case. >> Divorce isn't an option for me under any
circumstance
in my marriage. Um, >> even if he cheated on you. >> Yeah,
I wouldn't leave him. >> Who is running around like a headless
chicken causing havoc across the internet and we need to talk
about it. And so, let me introduce you to Savannah >> A
lot of women will ask me, they're like, "How did you become a
stay at home wife at such a young age?" I'm 19. Women, it is
much easier to trust God and to trust your husband than to be
a control freak. >> A lot of my wisdom,
>> Hold on. That's a rough 19 right there. Okay, I hate
to say it. That's a rough
>> Not so much in the Tik Tok clip, the next one, but that's
a rough 19 right there. Okay. Why? Who? Why are you getting lip
filler at 19?
Why are you trying to look like a Why you Why
Why would this happen? People ask me, they're like, "How did
you become a stay at home wife at such a young age?" I'm >> Women,
it is much easier to trust God and to trust your husband than
to be a control freak. >> A lot of my wisdom comes from
how many books I read. >> I mean, gay people don't contribute
anything to society at all. Consent doesn't exist in marriage.
>> That Alan Turing guy was a total drag on the human race.
That guy, that Alan Turing guy,
that guy, okay, gay people contribute nothing, >> dude.
The whole reason that you put a whole bunch of lip filler and
Botox into your face is because the gays sister. >> So,
I personally don't think women should vote. And this is why I
say all the time that I'm an anti-feminist because modern feminism
is poison. >> And the patriarchy was just paternal >> Women
specifically. It is so important that you stay attractive to
your husband. I had the businesses. I had the career. I know
how to work. >> How old are you? >> This is like
>> I'm 19. Here's my 9 to5 as a full-time wife. Isn't this
like Kidology's bread and butter of hatred where it's um like
she hates Pikmis, right? Isn't that her whole thing is like she
gets accused of being called a Pikmi so she hates >> Is
it? >> Or is she? I thought she's like a a fem
>> She She was a fem cell.
>> But like I'm just saying I think she hates Pikmis a
lot. I think >> go to all of my beauty appointments for
the day. >> Every time I say things like this, I get told
that I'm tearing down other women. No, the reason that I post
what I post is because I actually care about other women and
their well-being.
Now, Savannah is the internet's latest tradife. She's a part
of a cycle I've noticed that happens every couple of years. Basically,
a traditional Christian god-fearing woman gets married and she
decides that because she's now secured a husband, she therefore
has somehow imbued centuries old wisdom about everything marriage.
When it comes to intimacy with your spouse, we are called, we
have an obligation and a duty to um not deprive our spouse and
to come together often. And a lot of people hate that. But I'm
like, we have a duty and an obligation to follow Christ even
if it doesn't make us happy all the time. >> And because
she's a traditional God-fearing Christian woman, she's I'm sorry
cuz she said a duty to come
Are they talking about? >> Yeah.
He looks so sad.
>> He looks He unironically This looks like an ISIS hostage
video. If this guy was in an orange jumpsuit, I'd expect his
head to be on the floor in about 30 >> This is like when
your mom makes you like be filmed in her TikTok. What?
no. No. Nothing to do with Why are you looking No. Like >> I
just I Dude, I was
What? Where are you going with this? Sorry. >> No. Okay.
You're like, let's say your mom has a Facebook, she has a Tik
Tok, and so she takes pictures of you, she wants to take a film.
Oh, look, I'm out to dinner with my son. >> Yeah. Well,
that was that was actually the other one we watched with Kidology
was her doing the boy mom thing. >> Yeah. You don't want
to be there. This is what you look like when your mom just makes
you go on social media. >> This guy looks both sad and
dejected. Sorry. He looks sad and dejected, but he also looks
like kind of like a Fallout NPC. I feel like I recognize him
from like a Fallout New Vegas run. Am I the only one picking
up that vibe? Anyone else see that? I don't know how to explain
it. He looks like a follow New Vegas NPC.
>> This looks like us.
>> Okay. Also, yes, but like don't tell them that. >> A
lot of people hate that, but I'm like, we have a duty and an
obligation to follow Christ even if it doesn't make us happy
all the time. >> And
dude. Mhm.
>> Dude, this guy, is she his beard or what was that? That
was a lot of sassy energy, wasn't it? >> Follow Christ
even. >> Trust me, I can in terms of Mhm. I can determine
sass with a lot of a lot of confidence. Okay, that was pretty
sassy. >> That explains the face that he made when she
said, "You have a duty to make each other come at the same time
or whatever. Come together." >> He's like, "Huh,
>> I hate the vagina." >> Even if it doesn't make
us happy all the >> And because she's a
traditional God-fearing Christian woman. She's usually between
the ages of 18 and 24. Her newfound wisdom must be spread far
and wide. And what better medium than Instagram and Tik Tok.
>> Your husband does not need a nagging
>> And because she's a Christian,
>> oh my god, this person spitting. >> No, bro. If
you want if you want the people around you to be strong, right?
There's a lot of negativity on the internet. There are a lot
of trolls on the internet. If they can't handle you, they can't
handle anything. They are only as strong as the battles you prepare
them for.
>> This is why >> he doesn't know what I mean. Believe
in humility or treating one's neighbor as you would have them
treat you. Oh no. There is no doing unto others when the ragebait
economy offers you a wealth of modern advantages like money and
ego. Two things that we know our good lord cherishes above all
else. Man, I really miss being a Christian. Savannah describes
herself as a former liberal who after the pandemic and witnessing
the degeneracy of Black Lives Matter found her Republican >> Wait
the Wait, there was so much degeneracy during the PL during the
I was just about to say pandemic pandemic. Okay. There was so
much degeneracy to choose from. How the do you pick Black Lives
Matter? This is the most degenerate time on planet Earth.
>> I I don't know. So many people were cooped up for so
long that they started engaging in the weirdest,
right? And then
this guy's like, "You know what?" This woman is like, "You know what?
It's BLM. BLM was the degenerate shit." Huh? >> I I personally
thought the degenerate was maybe how many people started selling
their nudes and
>> Yeah. Like Only Fans took off like Yeah, dude. All kinds
of crazy [__] took off. Okay. got weird during the
pandemic. Chud Logic started messaging a bunch of different trans
people during the the pandemic. Okay. Was weird. >> Everyone
Everyone was going online and finding out actually what was going
on on the internet. I mean, I I joined like the internet. I I
ended up here because of the pandemic.
>> Pandemic, man. >> In homophobic, anti-feminist
calling. She decided not to go to law school as she planned and
instead married her boyfriend when she was 18 years old after
they started dating when she was still in high school. >> But
the day that Noah and I met in person, we had maybe been like
talking. >> Wait, did she say how old her husband is? Did
I >> go over Instagram for like a week? But then we decided
to actually meet in person pretty quickly after that. The second
that I saw that man, the Holy Spirit or whatever you want to
call it just in my head was like, "That's your >> Savannah
was 17 and he was 20. >> We both do not have college. >> Okay,
that's not that bad. I guess yeah, it's not bad. >> Yes,
I I knew it before she said it. Interestingly, deciding to get
married or not was all contingent on whether Savannah won her
Miss Florida pageant. And because she was runner up, a wedding
had to be planned. and I was competing in Miss Florida USA at
the time. So, he went to that pageant with me and I was kind
of like, "Okay, whatever happens with this pageant, like if I
were to win, obviously I can't get married. You can't get married
as a title holder or I guess I guess you can't be married as
a title holder. I don't know. But I just knew that that wasn't
going to happen if I had won that title." And I ended up placing
second runner. >> You think the Holy Spirit told her that,
>> I don't think the Holy Spirit told her anything. the
Holy Spirit. This guy is the one unless you win that beauty pageant.
Okay. >> And then and then I'm sending you a signal. Okay.
>> I'm the Holy Spirit. I don't know what's going to happen.
That's a that's your first clue. Okay. The Holy Spirit just didn't
give you clear directions. They gave you conditional directions.
That's not required. Okay. They they know they >> And then
that's when we started conspiring like, "Okay, we want to move
to this bigger city. We want to get married. Here's the plan."
like here's the like okay we want >> that's when we started
conspiring when I got second place that's when we started >> in
that pageant
and then that's when we started conspiring like okay we want
to move to this bigger city we want to get married here's the
plan like here's the goal how are we going to get there >> that
is the most 18-year-old thing I have ever heard I didn't win
a beauty pageant so I got married for a traditional wife who
absolutely loves to be at home serving her man Savannah seems
to have a lot of time on her hands time that she spends appearing
on podcast after podcast after podcast after podcast. >> What
do you think about uh She's just going to say it's wrong. She
just going to say it's a sin. It's a sin, right? >> Who
cares what she has to say? She's supposed to be a trad wife.
She's supposed to be a stay-at-home wife.
Why is anybody having her opinions on what she thinks about?
>> Cuz they need women who are young and attractive to
come on their shows and say women should shut the up. As a woman,
I believe women should shut the up. And that's what she's willing
to do. That's like that's what people want. >> that is.
So why do they even pretend? Why do they even ask her questions?
Have her come on and just sit there and then you and the guy
talk so people really understand what the [__] you're
talking about when you say >> practice what you preach.
>> This is what a trad wife is to me. >> Speak when
spoken to, but in a non-misogynist way cuz she's the >> Yeah,
it's a sin. It's against God. It is a sin. Like factually, >> it
is a sin. >> It's not natural. I mean, gay people don't
contribute anything to society at all. Like, you can't you can't
create children. And it's it's actually if they do decide to
get married, quote unquote, like sign a contract, it's not a
marriage either. >> Huh. It's like the gays aren't responsible
for the highest adoption rates in modern history. Or that LGBTQ
plus businesses contribute $2 trillion to the US economy every
year. Say it ain't so, Joe. Say it ain't so.
>> I was going to say like, how do you even get on the
conservative like business business bro like grinder?
uh what do you call it like rising grind crew podcast and go
gay people can't contribute anything when these guys are all
about working your your off to get ahead in life. Yeah, the grind
set crew >> also most of the conservative influencers are
gay.
>> Yeah, I was actually a great point like >> they
have wives. Like literally, I it would be shocking if you could
imagine her getting on Fresh and Fit and looking Myron in the
eyes and going, "Gay people contribute nothing to the economy."
And then he has to sit there and go, "You're right. You're they
contribute nothing." >> He would say, "Absolutely. They
contribute nothing. Gay people and black people and immigrants
and the feds and women." He just >> And only one of those
things is he lying about. Okay. >> Jesus. you you you've
been in this space much longer and you've been married longer
and so it was just really encouraging to hear that from you and
then when you invited me on your podcast I was like this is going
to be amazing. I'm so excited. >> I was so happy to find
out that you were a trades
cuz I was like this girl is so pretty. I just love how trades
have podcast businesses nowadays. It's like if Jesus decided
to become a Roman soldier. There's just a cognitive dissonance
there that I cannot overlook with a straight face. And to learn
everything and submissive, you can join Housewife Savannah's
submissive society for $19 a month. She currently has 120 members,
which means that this anti-work, anti-feminist, anti-girl bossing
trading
$2,280
a month. The Lord works in mysterious ways. Now, Savannah arguably
went viral after her trad provider husband allowed her to temporarily
step out of the earth and home and make it big on the Fresh and
Fit and Whatever podcast. Uh, number one, if she's a >> There
it is. There it is.
There it is. She actually will go say it to Myin's
>> We were insane. >> Informed on the Fresh and Fit
podcast that one of Savannah's red flags for woman is if a woman
has ever been to >> And if she's been to Miami, Dubai,
or any other party saying, "Yo,
that's why
>> I wonder where the Fresh and Fit podcast is located.
And Republican Jesus said, "I will hold others to bizarre, impossible
standards that I would never under any circumstances
of myself and my followers." Praise be. And you know it is because
we know Myin and uh the other the conventionally attractive one,
>> they don't let you come up with your
Their goal is to humiliate you. They don't let you come up with
your man. So her tried wife
going to make it seem like, oh, I'm sus of women who go to Miami.
You did go to a fresh and fit podcast and you left your man at
home. Clown. So incredibly progressive of Savannah's trad husband
to allow his submissive, cloistered wife into the den of whoring
sinners that permeate these Red Pole spaces. It kind of makes
you ponder whether trad is really even a thing in our digital
modern age. On the Fresh and Fit podcast, Savannah would also
say that another one of her red flags is if a woman is in her
quote masculine energy and is a bread winner. >> And you
know what? Every single one of you has a condom and I have a
car. >> She says this a lot actually. And I find this so
interesting considering she describes her mother as a woman who
was always in her masculine energy and was a bread winner. And
yet Savannah has a lot of grace for her mother. I grew up I I
say I would say I grew up in a different dynamic than I ever
wanted for my marriage. Like my mom was very much in her masculine
and took care of everything. Like she was the bread winner which
is totally fine. Um but my dad was also working so they were
both working and then she was also taking care of the household
chores. So she did like everything in the house. Had really no
support from my dad. Um and he was also not the head of the household.
So, I think that because she was in her masculine, it made my
dad not be in his masculine. And then because my dad never stepped
up to be in his masculine, she had to take on that role. >> And
yet, contrary to what she says about her masculine mom and her
feminine dad, Savannah will use them as a quintessential example
of a healthy Christian marriage. >> It is your responsibility
to stay attractive to your spouse. Just because you found the
one doesn't mean it's time to let yourself go. Obviously, both
of you are going to change as you age, but that doesn't mean
to stop taking care of yourself. I'm really lucky to have a great
example of this growing up. Both of my parents still go to the
gym. They still eat healthy. They still take care of themselves,
and they both look amazing. Just to reiterate, this is a masculine
woman with a feminine man. everyone. Interestingly enough, Savannah,
a submissive tradife, spends a lot of her time online defending
her dominant man, which fascinates me because again, this cognitive
dissonance just hits me, slaps me across the face time and time
again. Jesus turns the other cheek, but not Savannah. >> The
woman who started this whole rumor and who started making viral
videos about my husband, which encouraged other people to go
viral off of it, was the woman from the Whatever podcast. And
because I shared my story about getting married at 18, she immediately
called my husband a groomer, even though he's only three years
older than me. I dare any of you raging lunatic leftist to come
up to my face or my husband's face in public and say that to
my face or his face. You could easily sit behind the screen.
You can easily post your viral little videos. You can easily
hide behind a screen and post comments. But what I know none
of you would ever do. >> Try saying that to my face, bro.
Try saying that to my face, bro. >> She didn't just say
that to me or my husband's face. This is the woman who you guys
go to Disney World and she gets you in a fight
>> It's come up to our >> It would be over the stupidest
thing, too.
It would be over like >> Are you just Are you going to
let this guy just step on my flip-flop? I spilled my drink, >> dude.
That would even be better. I feel like it would be like it would
be like two guys like trying to go oh it would be like in the
parking lot like going for a parking space and some guy gets
to the parking space just before you. She's like oh you're just
going to let that guy like totally be the real man and >> he's
going to get bitched out by that guy and now we have to park
further and then I'm not going to get the fast pass in time.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And say that because you know exactly what
would happen. I am not in the turning the cheek business. Sorry.
Especially when you berade my husband. When you try to attack
a marriage. >> What kind of submissive wife gets online
to vehemently, aggressively, and antagonistically defend her
man's honor? You guessed it, a modern one. This not turning the
other cheek doesn't sound very feminine and biblical to me. But
that doesn't matter because I'm just one of those lousy, indoctrinated,
hateful >> Feminism. Feminism. Feminism. Feminism. Feminism.
Feminism. Feminism. Feminism. Feminism. Feminism. Feminism. Feminism.
Feminism. Feminism. Feminist. Feminism. Feminism. Feminism. Feminism.
Feminism. Feminism. Feminism. Feminism. Feminism. Feminists love
to preach about women's >> Feminism has been one of the
things that has made our society so sick. It's like probably
the number one thing. It's, you know, it's caused LGBTQ LGBTQ
transgenderism. It's caused most of the, you know, the the culturally
sick things that we're dealing with. >> Modern feminism
is poison. >> You know, I consider a good dose of feminism
equivalent to Eve eating from the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil. You take a bite from that apple, from that poison,
and you're exposed to the world. You form opinions and you don't
go back to a place of ignorance which according to Savannah she
herself is a very good example of. She was exposed to liberalism
and feminism but decided of her own free will to choose God,
republicanism, homophobia, transphobia, xenophobia, the list
goes on. Savannah believes that feminism went wrong at the point
of conception. >> So you'd agree that feminism has made
women less happy across the board. >> Yeah. Yes. >> Where
where do you believe it went >> From the beginning feminism
was never a good thing. She like all rage baiting child wives
believes women shouldn't >> I mean I so I personally don't
think women should vote. We lost in uh what was it 2020 because
women single women were voting. >> People will say you
know the first wave of feminism was great like it gave women
the right to vote and it gave women the right to work. I don't
want to do any of >> Uh I don't think women can vote. I
think we should repeal the 19th and everyone doesn't like that.
But
you know if maybe if you're a married man you get two votes.
I don't know. I just love how a staple of Savannah's resentment
with feminism is that feminists are supposedly trying to force
a certain way of life on women like her. And
>> the way of life she explicitly chooses despite being
married, right? Like the exact way of life. Like she is literally
being like a business-minded person who's getting her bag, getting
her money, building a business, being an
>> And she's like, "I can't believe feminism would try
to force this on people. I'm so happy I'm a trad." >> Yeah.
And if it weren't for feminism, you couldn't do this. >> Under
feminism, you actually can. You can literally be the t wife and
you could be the grifting td wife. You're >> dude. I I
want to watch this [__] clean any sink full of dishes.
I just want to see it happen. I want her to go and like pretend
like she knows where even the dish soap is in her house >> and
not and not just load the
>> Show me that you know how to clean a dish with your
hand. >> Yeah, exactly. Do you know what a sponge
>> You know, first I Yeah, I don't believe she does. >> She's
willing to strip our right to vote away because she personally
doesn't want to vote and she doesn't want the right to work.
And Republican Jesus said, "I shall strip these women of their
right to vote and work. Schools will close, hospitals will fold,
the economy will collapse, and Savannah, my child, you will no
longer be able to get your nails done." Praise be. Savannah hates
feminists, even though thanks to feminism, she as a woman was
allowed to go to school and learn things like how to read and
how to form opinions on her own. Thanks to feminism, she had
the choice to get married or to go to law school. And because
of feminism, she chose to marry her husband. And we'll get to
him. He adds a good sprinkle of spice to this beige rage baiting
grift. But one thing that him and Savannah most definitely do
have is good hair. And in my attempt to make my hair healthy
and my wigs silky smooth, I use Kit, the kind sponsor of today's
video. Now, I was stunned that Kit wanted to work with me because
I have been buying Kit accessories from my local drugstore.
>> you enjoy Kit as much as I do. Now, one thing that I've
noticed about Savannah, which actually gives me hope for her,
is that because her rage? >> Why is she Why is she got
a hair sponsor? Okay. What the [__] Why? Why is that
a thing? >> What? A hair sponsor? >> Yeah, why she
got a hair sponsor? What do you mean? What's a hair sponsor?
>> Uh, hair care sponsor.
>> You mad? >> Little bit. >> Why can't she
have a hair care sponsor? >> Cuz she doesn't show her hair
on her
>> That's hair in front of you. You think you don't have
to clean a wig?
You have to wash and you have to shampoo and condition a wig.
>> No, you don't. >> Yes, you do. >> No, you
don't shampoo a wig. >> Yes, you do. >> With like
human shampoo. >> Yes. Oh my goodness. If it's human hair.
Yes, with human shampoo. Okay. >> Basing beliefs are so
extreme and ill thought out. She ends up having to defend conclusions
that have no basis in
>> Why are you guys acting like I'm the dumb one when I've
never had a wig? I'm just like, "Oh, I didn't think wigs were
I thought it was synthetic, man.
>> Some are synthetic." Yeah,
>> I literally never had a wig. Never had any reason to
know anything about wigs. You guys are freaking the [__]
out. I don't know wigs. The [__] >> Any reality?
Savannah works in a lot of logical fallacies. Her arguments sound
convincing. She says them with conviction and self assuredness.
And yet, as we're about to see, it leads to her claiming to abide
by standards that could cause Savannah and many of the women
who listen to her great emotional, psychological, and physical
harm. For instance, she claims that men are logical and women
are emotional, which explains why women ought to defer all decision-m
and authority to their husbands. Yes, we make decisions together
as a married couple because we are a team, but at the end of
the day, he is the head of the household and I'm going to follow
him before I follow my own feelings because women are controlled
by their emotions and men are controlled by logic. So most of
the time, actually 100% of the time, he's been right. >> Now,
according to Savannah, her husband has been right 100% of the
time. >> So most of the time, actually 100% of the time,
he's been right. And yet on another podcast, she'll then say
that her husband hasn't always made the best decisions, but she'd
still, against her better judgment, follow him anyway. >> I
I will say that beginning of our marriage, there were a couple
decisions my husband made a mistake on, and I think that they're
they're human. They're going to make mistakes. >> What
were the mistakes? >> Off the top of my h my head, like
one was financial, like we sold one of the cars and it I don't
know. In the end, like one of it actually ended up being okay,
but in the at the time, >> what the [__] kind
of trad
Why are you on the Whatever podcast listing off his mistakes,
saying that he makes mistakes. >> He sold a car. >> The
autonomy on this one, >> I'd say be a little
>> we were considering
>> the autonomy on this. >> Ultimately, I gave the
decision to him. Um, that was that's like one I can think of
off the top of my head. But the other one was probably smaller.
But yeah, I would say that that they the goal is for them to
learn from that mistake and then to grow from it. >> Doing
something that isn't in your best interest because of your moral
absolutism isn't only stupid, it can be incredibly harmful. For
instance, Savannah will say that divorce isn't an option for
her because divorce is morally wrong. Which therefore leads her
down a logical fallacy where she then has to say that she'd stay
with her husband even if he serely cheated on >> Uh divorce
isn't an option for me under any circumstance in my marriage.
Um >> even if he cheated on you? >> Yeah, I wouldn't
leave him. >> She going to endure. What is nobody going
to ask? Is Brian not there to ask the actual follow-up to this?
What if he starts slapping you around? You can't leave. I
>> That's crazy.
>> He probably knows that I need to be sly. >> My
husband wouldn't cheat on me. That's
>> I know you're a man. Like you're a husband. If he cheated
on, you would tolerate it. >> It would be extremely hard
to get through. I think that that would be probably the hardest
thing I went through in my marriage. But I don't believe in ending
a marriage. >> What if it was reoccurring infidelity? >> I
mean, we'd have we'd have an issue there. Like, but yeah, I I
wouldn't leave my husband. Even if you did it mult multiple times,
I wouldn't leave my
>> There are many reasons for staying with somebody who
cheats on you. And none of those reasons are a positive for anybody
but the cheater. Staying with your husband because your moral
absolutism tells you to, even if he cheats or abuses you, is
incredibly harmful to preach to your audience. Now, one thing
Savannah hates is when people use her age against her. She compares
herself to Timothy in the Bible, implying that God has given
her this gift and passion to give marriage advice as a just turned
20-year-old woman who has been married for no more than 2 years.
Um, Timothy was believed to be in his late teens/ early 20s when
he was called to lead a
>> And so the the Bible literally warns believers, do not
look down on people cuz they're young. But Timothy in the Bible,
he led a church at he might have been like 17, 18, 19, 20, kind
of in the same age range I am. And
>> now here's the question. Did she ask Charlie Kirk or
actual chat GPT if there was a young person in the Bible she
could reference to back up why she should be listened to about
marriage advice? Was it Christian chat GBT? Charlie Kirk, of
course, or actual chat >> Man, it was probably neither.
His her husband probably told her. I just I think it's so funny
that she just googled like >> she basically just googled
like young person in Bible question mark and this is who came
up >> and he was like God like am I like am I qualified
to lead this church and God was like yeah you're qualified like
I have given you the gifts and the skills to do this and so the
comments at always at me are like you're too young to give marriage
advice no one should trust you like that's that's what they try
to discredit me with >> it's like when Andrew Tate compared
compared himself to Nelson Mandela and Martin Luther King. It's
as if she watches Andrew Tate in her spare time. >> We
did homemade pizzas tonight, which was so fun. They turned out
really good. Post a homemade crust recipe soon, and then we ended
the night with family >> Ah, of course. Are we at all surprised?
And like the world's most celebrated human trafficker, Savannah
has found herself in a few controversies. Her first and biggest
being her opinions on consent. And this can really show us why
it is so important to think hard and long before you convince
yourself that you are a protege of marriage advice before you
convince yourself that you are Paul the Apostle's protege. So
earlier this year, Savannah went super viral for a series of
Tik Toks she made about her controversial takes on marriage and
intimacy. According to Savannah, consent doesn't exist in marriage.
Number two, consent doesn't exist in marriage. I know this is
going to a lot of people off, but when you get married, your
body belongs to your husband, and your husband's body belongs
to you. Two become one. Body, mind, soul, and spirit. >> What
is one thing you've said publicly that still stands even after
backlash?
>> Consent doesn't exist in marriage. >> I used to
think it went without saying, but it's 2025, so I'll say it loud
and proud. This is why critical thinking is so important. This
is why schooling, especially reading, writing, comprehension,
and critique are so so >> Thank God that we're defunding
the Department of Education.
>> Does Codology think that this person doesn't understand
that what they're saying is stupid?
>> She just said, "Thank God we're defunding the Department
of Education
and critique are so so vital. >> Thank God that we're defunding
the Department of Education because kids and adults just keep
getting dumber." And suddenly this all makes a lot more sense
because surely if I'm to give her the benefit of the doubt, if
your body belongs to your husband and your husband's body belongs
to you, if your body that belongs to him isn't in the mood for
his body which belongs to you, he ought to respect that in order
to maintain the harmony of that argument. No. Well, according
to Savannah, that is not what that means. Actually, in fact,
submitting to your husband is the least you can do. >> Rule
number three is we never deprive each other. And I will never
understand why women complain about having to with their husbands.
Like after everything this man does for me puts his roof over
my head, it's like the least you can do. I love how again she
objects to feminism imposing its beliefs and expectations onto
her, but she's trying to impose her fundamentalist anti-critical
interpretation of biblical marriage onto the internet. For money
and clout, Republican Jesus is quaking in ecstasy right now.
Now, I can't take any of this seriously at all. The only woman
who I would ever hear say something so ignorant and lacking in
introspection are women who are privileged enough to have never
been or violated. Women who are privileged and sheltered enough
to have never known or never cared about other women who have
been assaulted or violated or uncritical women who have been
fortunate enough to go their lives with their autonomy respected
by men. And by the way, Savannah has feminism to thank for that.
And I am so glad that she's had that reality, has had that privilege
which feminism has granted her. But it does tell me how young,
how naive, how lacking in critical thinking skills or how simply
malicious she is in assuming that her privilege is a universal
experience that we should base expectations of consent on. She
defends herself by saying that a loving husband who has a biblical
understanding of consent would never ever harm his wife. >> Everything
I say is coming from a healthy biblical marriage uh where the
husband is a loving husband and the wife is a submissive and
respectful wife. And when I say the phrase, okay, when when you
get married, you give up your conjugal rights, it also says that
in I think verse three or four. Uh the husband gives up his conjugal
rights to the wife. The wife, >> is that not is that not
just enforcing
>> Wife gives gives up her conjugal rights to the husband.
That word pretty much means consent in today's day and age. >> This
whole biblical marriage defense is also so
dewy. I can tell you >> like I think you have a duty to
have kids or something in Christianity. Like I think there is
stuff to like family plan, right? >> Um there's no duty
if you are a woman who's born barren. It's you're not >> sure.
Sure. But I mean like to the best of your ability or something.
But I I just don't think there's anything in the Bible about
like oh consent doesn't matter at all.
I don't think that conjugal I I assume that that just means like
literally you can only have sex with each other. >> Dude,
the Bible is so [__] twisted. Okay. There's the whole
thing where Lot like the daughters
the father offered his daughters for the village to
so that they didn't rap his guests and then later on they go
in the cave and they their father. I'm pretty sure the Bible
don't give a about consent in the way that she's talking. At least
not after the
in the Old Testament. Yeah, that's Lot's daughters. People have
like a romanticized idea of
maybe some of what the Bible teaches, right? There's a lot of
people in the world that's like, "Oh, God would not >> God
the Bible doesn't support murder
or war or violence."
And it's just like, "No, no, he's pretty violent." >> No,
I think God was God [__] with a genocide here and
there heavy.
>> Okay. Um, also I Googled it and it seems like this is
more this is a little bit different. Okay, chat GBT says is a
little different, but
it's fine. It is probably it's about it is about like mutual
consent, but it's not saying one side it's not saying one side
can force on the other. It's saying you shouldn't withhold it
from the other person unilaterally is like what it says, >> It's
like deny deprive kind of thing. >> Yeah. You should >> there's
an idea of like what love is. Love is outlined in in there. Yeah.
>> Yeah. tell you from personal and impersonal experience
that many men, Christian or otherwise, can do you harm while
believing themselves to be good and healthy people. Relationships,
marriage, and life are far more complicated and messier than
Savannah's naive privilege will allow her to >> My body
is my husband's, his body is mine. Um, and so I don't I don't
deny him every other day just cuz I don't feel like it and vice
versa. And that was what I meant by that statement. Um, and I
I made it very clear that if you don't believe in the Bible,
you don't have to listen to anything I'm saying because it's
not going to make sense to you at all. >> Firstly, why
would you post about fundamentalist biblical marriage on Tik
Tok? And >> that's uh that's pretty [__] up,
dude. That's pretty >> not expect to get major backlash.
Secondly, biblical marriage may grant a man consent in some ancient
theoretical fantasy of sanctified marriage, but consent in reality
is far more complex than that. Let's dumb this down since Savannah
thinks that we're all getting dumber and dumber. Okay. When I
get onto an airplane, that is not me consenting to every and
any possible eventuality of getting onto >> Wait,
is that Missy that just changed their name?
No, it's not. Somebody just changed their name. Who just changed
their name? The mRNA go exploder. Who just did that? Is that
Riyle? No, it's not Riyle.
[__] I should know who it is. Hold on. No, it is
Riyle. Riyle changed his name. What a weirdo. Why'd you do that?
The weird name, bro. This guy. This guy. What the [__]
is going on
>> That plane. I don't consent to all of the unforeseen
that may happen when I get onto that plane. I don't consent to
antisocial behavior when I get onto that plane. I don't consent
to the pilot being under the influence when I get onto that plane.
I don't consent to snakes on that plane. And I sure as hell don't
consent to on that plane. Consenting to biblical marriage does
not and should never mean submitting to what Savannah is inadvertently
implying. >> Divorce isn't an option for me under any circumstance.
I don't believe in ending a marriage. I wouldn't leave my husband.
>> Thanks to feminism, many women from all faiths and backgrounds
are being exposed to the fact that they are equal human beings
and I am elated. So since caing that she'd never ever delete
this controversial, horrendous Tik Tok >> and I refuse
to take down any of my videos. I get backlash because I said
what I said and I said it and I'm not going to take anything
back. >> Savannah deleted the Tik Tok. She has also made
sure to do damage control by going on to podcasts, giving us
some much needed context into her controversial opinion. >> People
take short form content and they take one thing you said and
they completely run with it instead of being like, well, why
did she say that? Like, let me go look at her other content.
let me go watch her long form content maybe. But they'll take
one thing. It's just like with Andrew Tate or anybody else, Tucker
Carlson, Candace Owens, anybody else who's controversial. They'll
take one thing or one allegation and run with it instead of actually
understanding why they said that thing. >> I love how it's
everybody else's fault that Savannah said that consent in marriage
doesn't exist. We just run away with the malicious lies, you
guys. We didn't actually listen to what she was saying. The wider
conversation she was trying to start on a rage baiting Tik Tok.
It's like how her girl Candace Owens is now running around like
a headless chicken because she's being sued for making an eight-part
series claiming that Bridgetette Mcron is a man. But Candace
is the victim, brethren. She is the victim of a malicious left-wing
attempt to bully and defame her. I hate how in real time we are
seeing the mortifying consequences of a culture that no longer
values critical thinking and rewarding harmful stupidity with
money and exposure. Get me out of this timeline, please. And
this is what Savannah really represents to me. She really represents
the devaluation of critical thinking that is becoming the easy
way out of us doing better. The easy way out of us confronting
a precarious scary world. And I get it. Right now there is a
huge appeal in young women rejecting a lot of what modern life
tells us to strive for because so much of what we're apparently
working toward is just no longer guaranteed. Going to college
no longer guarantees you a job on par with your education. Working
hard in your career no longer guarantees you a promotion or job
security. no longer guarantees you a pension or self-fululfillment.
Even voting as a woman no longer guarantees that your rights
to your own bodily autonomy are going to be protected. And this
growing narrative of I'm just a girl or I just want to stay at
home and bake banana bread or I just want a man to pay for my
stress-free existence sounds great and self-protecting in theory.
And I'm so so sorry, but there is no price you can put on autonomy,
on independence, or on self-dignity. A man cannot give you those
things. A relationship can't give you those things. It can validate.
>> Okay, I need to pause this cuz I'm uh starting to fade
at the end of the stream here, but I need to pull up Shamu's
Twitter cuz he uh he had a David update that I want to take a
look at. Hello. Hello.
I want to take a quick look at this David update that he posted.
David prisonbound. A video has resurfaced from 2024 alleging
David was paying kids money to hide his relationship with Se
Celeste, the 15-year-old girl found dead in his car this month.
She was 14 when she died, though. The video was filmed 9 months
prior to her body being discovered in David's car. >> Ethan
M. >> Popular artist got caught giving thousands of dollars
to kids. Now, why did he do this? To hide his little secret of
him dating a minor. >> Yep. Who knows if he's still dating
this minor. and people coming. Proof proof.
>> Why the else would he randomly go
>> un unnoticed? No one knows about this. To meet kids,
bring them canes, give them thousands of dollars.
Why else would he do that? Why else would any celebrity do that?
You know exactly why. And I'm not just guessing here. This is
a picture from someone who knew the girl and they told me this
>> Wow. So, it's the same picture that we've seen a couple
times already saying that's what's happening here. David is paying
people to keep quiet about his minor girlfriend. Jamu says you
can see the date at the bottom of the video. I wasn't really
sure to uh what to think about the blackmail stuff, but seeing
proof of videos talking about it 9 months prior makes it much
more plausible. Yeah, I think there was some indication that
it was from back then as well. So, anyway, I saw him post that.
I wanted to check that out real quick. I didn't realize it was
just going to be the same thing that we'd already seen on stream,
but I thought it was going to be interesting. I thought it could
be interesting. Thought it could be neat. Don't take Tylenol.
Okay. All right. >> Those things, but you are the source
and will always be the source. >> Isn't it so crazy that
feminism does the exact opposite of empowering women? It is not
giving you freedom. It is actually silencing you. It's funny
how feminism actually just gave the worst type of men exactly
what they wanted. I mean having as much emotionless as possible
only fans running around half naked their babies >> also
Savannah the new voice of empowered >> um I don't believe
in under any circumstance including
cases whatever it may be because those are only 1% so I think
it should be completely illegal there >> does she know
what an exception is >> does she know how much 1% equates
to >> in terms of people >> I don't think so it's
just like uh people who have like calculated to rage rate personalities.
I don't know. I said it is what it is. >> Something so
introspection and so anti-critical thinking in a woman who made
the autonomous choice to be
My best friend from out of town was visiting a couple weeks ago
and she met my entire friend group and she came up to me and
said, "It is so cool how all of your friends don't have college
degrees, but they are wildly successful." And it is so true because
most of the time people that don't go to college kind of have
to fend for themselves. They have to think outside the box. They
have to use their brain to make money in order to make a living
instead of just handing a degree to an >> It's so interesting
to me that she equates being wildly successful. definitely didn't
use your brain to get your degree >> with being educated
especially in this economy being wildly success. >> Wait,
Accelerati said earlier, David being a popular artist has me
convinced I dimension shifted. What do you mean? David's music
was [__] good. >> No, it wasn't. >> Yeah,
it was. >> I'm very firm on the fact that that was very
mediocre music. That's like his music is like when um it's like
comparing
designer clothes to your favorite streamers like merch, their
teach their t-shirts or whatever. It's like no >> music
used to be something. >> Okay. Well, listen, I can't evaluate
Gen Alpha music. So,
and being educated aren't at all equitable. Being a wildly successful
fool is a historical phenomenon and will forever be one as our
current subject matter so confidently displays. >> You
also notice that people that didn't go to college and put a big
emphasis on school are able to think for themselves. They don't
believe everything that was taught to them in school. They don't
believe every single history book they've read. They don't believe
everything that the educ >> Dude, oh my god.
I'm sorry. I'm looking at some other stuff on the side as well.
Dude, as a Oh, I can't dude. We're going to have the same discourse
again this year. Uh Dan Clansancy responds to streamer safety
concerns regarding TwitchCon. Says the platform has a zero tolerance
policy. We take security extremely seriously every year. We build
on our successful approach have teams focused on this year round.
We have rules and standards. So this is about the kick streamers
who went last time right and like upset people. And Asmin Gold
post last year NMP and Wake were assaulted by a streamer and
Twitch didn't press charges or pursue any form of legal action
against him. Here's the video. >> Twitch streamer. Why
didn't NMP wake pursue charges? Why did Twitch have to pursue
charges? How did How did Twitch How does Twitch press charges?
Can 7-Eleven press charges for me if I if I get punched in the
face in 7-Eleven?
The se the the 7-Eleven could press charges for me. I thought
that was >> I thought that dude also streamed on Or is
that the one dude who was going around on kick assaulting people?
>> Yeah, I'm pretty sure it's the dude who went around
on kick. I'm pretty sure it's the dude who like licked NP's nipple.
Yeah, there was
on kick. >> It's a DBR DBR. >> Yeah, DBR and they
they blamed it on like every Kick streamer is a degenerate. This
one person. >> Yeah, it's the one dude. And and like
as post this and he's like, "Oh, why didn't uh why didn't Twitch
press charges?" It's like, I'm pretty sure I got kicked out.
I don't know what more they could have done. Why didn't NMP press
charges?
>> Yeah, good point. I don't I just don't
>> education system is telling them >> it's uncanny
how she claims to think for herself and yet all her views derive
from an uncritical and literal reading of biblical scripture.
I can't keep doing this. I can't keep pointing out the logical
fallacies. I feel like I'm going insane. This is probably going
to be a hard >> Well, that that's that's like what I'm
saying. Stalin sloth. I don't understand how they could do that.
But I genuinely believe that it is so much harder to become a
wife, to build a family, to serve, love, and nurture a husband
than it is to be a businesswoman or a woman with a really successful
career. Becoming a wife and stepping into the mindset and become
>> this just all in order to be when you change your name
back, you can get untimed out or when you stop doing the attention-seeking
thing. Becoming the woman that I needed to be for my husband
was 10 times harder than any business that I ever started.
>> This is like this is just so goofy. It's like
it's just rage. Again, I don't even want to get mad at it. It's
just so >> And jumping from being employed to being a full-time
business owner, becoming a wife was so much harder than any of
that. I had a lot of inner work to do. Now, I completely agree
with Savannah and I agree with her because I cannot imagine anything
harder than being a 19-year-old who has had the full force of
not just marital life thrust upon you, but the full force of
traditional patriarchal marital life thrust upon you. I cannot
imagine any career being harder than that. This woman in a matter
of a few months transitioned from single to married and based
on what she says she is now responsible for, i.e. fulfilling
her husband's needs whether she consents to it or not. Yes. Yes,
what she is doing is harder than being a girl bossing modern
businesswoman. And I cannot imagine what that does to one's brain
and mental well-being, especially in the long term. She's responsible
for running a whole household, obeying her husband, and did I
say fulfilling his intimate needs, consensually or otherwise.
And so, yes, I agree wholeheartedly with Savannah. Being a traditional
fundamentalist wife who is entirely dependent on your provider
husband at the mere age of 19 is most definitely harder than
being a self-sufficient woman with a career and at least some
options. And I will go further. Being a rage baiting influencer
who has the tormenting your frontal and temporal loes is definitely
harder than anything independent women go through on a daily
basis. >> I just have to say it is 3:30 p.m. on a Sunday.
I'm still in my pajamas.
I just made a fresh loaf of sourdough bread and I'm having another
cup of coffee.
I'm going to do a Sunday reset and then cuddle on the couch with
my husband. There is nothing better than being a wife. It's as
if you can't do these things while you're single or I don't know,
gay. This, brethren, is what you call the honeymoon phase. You
have no stress. It's a slow Sunday where you can just eat, cuddle,
and do nothing with your partner. And that is amazing for Savannah.
This phase lasts as long as your partner and you put effort into
your relationship. As long as everybody is feeling respected
and cherished, as long as your needs are being met in the relationship
and external stressors aren't undermining the strength of your
relationship. I wish this for everyone, but I also wish for you
not to be preached down to for having a job, for being stressed,
and statistically having a partner who doesn't take on the emotional
and household labor that you as a woman are expected to. Which
leads us to another of Savannah's major controversies. her allegedly
gay husband. So, when Savannah appeared on the Whatever podcast,
she got into a bit of a one-on-one tiff with a fellow creator
and former American Idol contestant, Erica Perry. Now, Erica
debuted on Tik Tok by starting a rumor that Savannah's husband
is gay. >> You guys, this is her manly, masculine husband
that she preaches about because she believes that feminine men
are toxic to society. Now, this resulted in a lot of people speculating
that Savannah must be in a lavender marriage, which is basically
a marriage between two people of differing orientations who marry
out of convenience, whether it be financial convenience or a
way to avoid stigma and discrimination from their religious.
>> No, no. Chill underscore chill. I'm like 2 minutes from
getting away. Please just chill. Please be cool. Thank you. Thank
you for the five gifted >> like 2 minutes from getting
away. Just let me be okay. >> Communities and families.
>> Men, if you get off to any other woman other than your
wife, you are committing >> She said getting off to other
women. If that woman is not your wife, it is adultery. But what
if you get off to a man that's not your wife? Is that one >> uh
Thank you for the five gifted though. Super appreciated. Thank
you. This little cookie here is making quite the stir on the
Tik Tok lately. Her name is Savannah. She is giving marriage
advice from what seems to be a lavender marriage. Savannah being
in a lavender marriage made a lot of sense to a lot of people
because in their minds, the only way she could wholeheartedly
claim that marital consent isn't necessary is if there isn't
even anything to consent about in the first place. Uh, this rumor
became a hot topic on Tik Tok, but the kettle would really over
boil when Savannah appeared on Michael Null's YouTube channel
alongside fellow lady conservative influence.
>> Where is she? >> We got a We got a Melanie Mac
sighting right there
YouTube channel alongside fellow lady >> Oh, that's that's
Emily Saves America, right? I'm pretty sure that's the [__]
who got fingered in the TP USA hotel lobby. Okay, >> always
say that. I'm pretty sure that's who that is. If I'm not mistaken,
I believe that's who that is. >> To have a little um a
little casual discussion about such things as whether women should
vote or have access to life-changing healthcare. Discussion about
such things. >> This is the worst panel you could have
convened for that discussion. What the >> Women should
vote or have access to life-changing healthcare as one does.
Now, something that is a universal with these conservative, god-fearing
influencer girlies is that they are fake as and they will do
anything to garner the toxic male validation they need to advance
their brand. And that means putting their values to one side,
taking their masculine energy by the fallopian tubes and attacking
their fellow conservative influencer girlies into the dust, which
again, cognitive dissonance. Anyway, one of these girlies, Trump
adoring Emily Wilson, yeed her feminine
>> I knew it. I knew this was Emily >> to the curb
and said the unthinkable.
>> Are you a pick me? Are you doing pic
>> I'm married. I'm married. I don't need to be picked.
I've already been picked. >> But every single thing you
say is literally appealing to men and usually hating on women
as well, which is funny cuz I would think if I was in a happy
marriage, I wouldn't even do like I would just go out and just
be happy and do my thing. I think the advice you give to women
is awful. I think it's at a detriment to them and I don't think
it comes from true happiness and I think it really does come
out of insecurity from being in frankly a lavender marriage as
everyone online can see. I disagree. I think so. >> Are
you that easily manipulated by Tik Tok rumors?
I've literally never heard this term before today, but it's a
lavender marriage. Uhoh.
Has had anyone else heard that term before today? Lavender marriage.
>> I had never heard that term before. Savannah, like the
god-fearing, submissive Christian that she is, forgot all about
her feminine energy and did the ultimate masculine move. She
decided to defend her man. >> What is it? Can you Can you
clear up for a millennial what's a lavender marriage? >> Man,
in 2 seconds. >> Oh, a lavender marriage is when you >> okay,
why do you think I called you out for hating specifically? >> Isn't
a lavender marriage usually >> berated my husband online?
You bered my husband for absolutely no reason. No, I just looked
at I just looked at two seconds. I was, "Oh, that's a gay man.
That's why she's
>> Dude, you could tell because I knew this person hung
out with Lav." You could tell exactly who this person would be
knowing that she's like a podcast with Laugh, right? >> I
knew exactly what she was going to say about the guy's husband.
Yeah, that guy's I honestly just lucky that she said it's a gay
man and not the Fler specifically. Okay. >> Now, Savannah's
husband is Noah and he's um he's spicy. >> Hold on, hold
on, hold on, hold on, hold on. What? Okay, that could be a straight
dude. Still could be a straight dude who's dressed up by his
wife. >> In the beginning, her husband looked like a Mexican
dude. >> Yeah, straight dude. >> This like a >> This
is one of the gayest pictures I've ever seen taken in my entire
life. >> That's not even how you show >> This is
not how a straight dude. This is like This is like explicitly
like the gayest picture I've ever seen. I'm going to be real.
I don't think straight guys usually have their beards cropped
like that. I just
like that tight that tight crop like that with the super low
body fat. It's just not usually a
>> Now, what I love about these rumors of Savannah's husband
having um having a little bit of the mountain air throbbing through
his veins is that husband having
>> having a little bit of the mountain air throbbing through
through his veins. Is
>> Oh, why I keep missing the picture. >> You got
a car. >> Is that it really does show how everything is
on a spectrum. um a continually moving individual spectrum. This
man, >> bro, I didn't I wouldn't even know without this
like latent homophobia, I'd have no idea Kidology was black.
Okay, I'm sorry. Like I >> Without the homophobia, >> without
the latent homophobia, like she's just totally all in on like,
yeah, this stupid >> I assume is as straight as a cucumber.
And that's the point. You can be a straight fundamentalist god-fearing
provider man and still use toner. You can still take quirky selfies
in the mirror doing a yoga girly tree pose. You can still have
the James Charles posture locked in and be a straight guy. And
I think it's so important to see that,
>> with these charlatans, these heteronormative grifters,
these just graduated from high school influencers cosplaying
as trad homemakers. Because like it or not, Savannah is a modern
woman and her husband is a modern
man. Oh, sorry. That's not mine. It must be his. Oh. Oh, sorry.
That man. >> Oh, is that is that supposed to be a grinder
sound effect or something? Is that what that's supposed to be?
And I don't recognize it cuz
I That has to be a grinder sound effect, right?
>> Must be. Why is she grinder? >> She's gay. She
was supposed to be gay for a long time. >> That's not mine.
It must be his. All credit for inspiring that joke goes to this
wonderful creator. Now, only a few days ago, the internet got
their first PR exposure to Savannah's own Jack Twist. And this
is what our dominant leader, provider, decision-making, head
of the household patriarch had to say about defending his wife's
honor online. >> Um, it's just kind of not my focus. And
I really don't feel the need to
stand up to something that isn't a real >> frankly. And
I don't mean to like sound like over masculine or anything. >> Oh,
don't worry, boo. >> Like like uh like I don't >> I
don't I don't I don't mean to sound like masculine or anything.
And I don't mean to like sound like over masculine or anything.
>> Oh, don't
>> I don't mean to sound over masculine. >> Yes,
that's what he said. Yes, that's what he said. >> Had to
say about defending his wife's honor online. >> Um, it's
just kind of not my focus. And I really don't feel the need to
stand up to something that isn't a real
>> And I don't mean to like sound like >> Do you
think this is like this is like the straightest outfit? This
is a straight outfit. He's got like the straightest outfit he
could possibly wear. He let his beard grow out. This is the straightest
this guy's ever looked in his entire life. Okay. >> Over
masculine or anything. >> Oh, don't worry, boo. >> But
it like I don't there's nothing until something affects our marriage
physically or in like the real life or like in the present moment,
then yes, I will act out and do what I need to do to defend and
protect what we have together. But until then, like it's it's
a waste of my time. It's a secret of my energy. I need to focus
on building my business and where I'm going and the current business
that I'm at and like focusing on investing into her and loving
her instead of like being all distracted with all of this like
noise that's just like complete like buffoonery and fake >> our
provider everyone letting his wife be the independent influencer
girl boss that she is and good on him taking the back seat and
letting her thrive living her best bigoted life. I cannot wait
to see what Savannah decides to try and go viral with next. I'm
sure it's going to be something out of this world, like women
shouldn't be allowed to leave the house after, I don't know,
sunset in case the Cullins ditch their vegetarian diet. But in
the meantime, don't listen to 19-year-olds.
>> The colors.
>> Can you do this one skit that is posted in stream chat?
>> Uh, yep. >> It's the the one posted by Star 11.
They said between the stars 11 in the kick chat, I believe. >> Yeah,
I don't know what this is. They said that they they posted it
um much >> Okay. All right. Well, we'll check this >> Ever.
Thank you so much for watching, brethren. Let me know what you
think and I'll see. >> Is is Between the Stars still here?
Between the Stars 11, you still in the the chat right now? Hello.
>> All of you very very soon in the next one. I'm
>> And Republican Jesus said, >> "Pick up my phone
and subscribe." Oh, shut up. Shut up. Shut up. >> We asked
25 black people to name something a black parent might say to
their child before whooping their
>> Lord have mercy. That's my That's my first one. >> You
going to learn today. >> You're going to learn today. You're
going to learn today is going to be a good one.
>> Bring that you more than it hurt me.
>> It's going to hurt me more than it hurts you. Same [__]
>> It's going to be hurt me more than hurt you. Yeah. Yeah.
There you go. This definitely should be wrong. >> Todd,
do you think you got one? >> I'm not one of your little
friends. I ain't one of your old friends and they never were.
>> Unfortunately, not enough. >> I'mma play this
one, man. I ain't get beat a lot, but I know people that did.
So, I think I got this. >> There was a lot of people writing
back about having to relive some childhood trauma for this one.
So, I apologize to the viewers who had to, you know, dig back
in archives a little bit. >> Keep playing with me. >> I
might have to ask my people about this >> Oh, that could
be a good one. >> He talking to the mustache. >> You
think I'm playing? And they're going to give it to him. >> More
points is very close. I'm going to say go to your room. >> Go
to your room.
>> Not up there. Really dig back into that childhood trauma.
>> You got one more time >> and not another. You
got one more time to guess an answer. That's two strikes >> that
I'm thinking about it. >> Picking the thing that you get
hit with. >> When you think about >> Go give me a
switch. >> No, no, not give me a switch. It's you give
them options. Which is it? Pick one and you have to go pick with
whether you want like the the wooden spoon, the belt or chunk
that >> then you pick the wrench. >> The wrench.
>> She hasn't seen Goodwill Hunting, so she doesn't even
get it. Could you imagine not having seen Goodwill Hunting?
That's so [__] up. >> You already basically
I already get the movie. You said it's a really smart
>> Flip his butt. Pull down your pants. >> Famous
last words. Pull down your pants.
>> Three strikes. No. Okay. Okay. >> Sit on down.
>> I'm glad nobody had to deal with that. I'm just going
to go with bring that ass >> No decent young fler,
>> Not up there. >> Oh, really? I know what it is.
>> We asked 25 black people to name something a black parent
must >> wait. Pause. Pause. It's number one. Did I I said
something else, didn't I? What else did I say? >> You going
to learn today? >> You going to learn today? Wait, they
already said you I said you going to learn today. >> No,
I said that. >> What did I say then? >> Nothing.
Abuse. >> I said I said you going to learn today.
what else could it be? It's not your >> Child before whooping.
>> You done it now. >> Number three.
Go get my
>> Okay. I Yeah. >> Oh my god. >> I I Yeah.
Go get me a switch is like what I remember from community cuz
it's >> go get my belt is usually >> go get and that
could be anything. My belt, my shoe.
>> A switch. >> Old school people down in the south.
Absolutely. And number one, >> I'mma whoop your ass. >> Oh,
did not tell you. This one is very
>> because this can be said before and during in between
slaps.
>> Didn't I >> Dad tell you to keep that TV off >> cuz
they had rhythm. So hopefully they hit on just on the tail, but
if you getting hit on all four beats, >> fall on the floor.
>> Yeah. No, sorry y'all. Um, but yeah, that's was a good
question. >> Okay, that was good. >> That was good.
That was good. >> Oh, Maximus is the one who
who told me about this in the stream chat. Okay.